Secretary of State Anthony blinken has
wrapped up his first visit to China
where he met president Xi Jinping and
other leaders officials say that they
agreed to at least try to reduce
tensions in the U.S China relationship
and before he left the country Lincoln
spoke with Chief Foreign Affairs
correspondent and faced the nation
moderator Margaret Brennan who joins us
now from Beijing with the wonders of
satellite Margaret good morning
good morning to you well Tony there were
no breakthroughs on tough issues but the
talks did not break down and that's seen
as progress now the two nuclear Powers
have agreed to try to stabilize this
very complicated intense relationship
it's a work in progress this is
something that we need to do in the
interests of both of our countries
secretary blinken left Beijing without
achieving a major U.S goal president Xi
Jinping still has not agreed to open
contact between the U.S and Chinese
militaries cut off since August the U.S
is concerned that a series of
provocative actions by China's military
like this fighter jet buzzing a U.S
surveillance aircraft in the South China
Sea raised the risk of miscalculation
during the Cold War the U.S and the
Soviet Union had that hotline is that
the kind of thing you're imagining is
less a hotline and more regular
engagement regular communication so that
they understand what we're doing and not
doing Espionage is also a top concern
China expanded a listening Post in
nearby Cuba in 2019 to surveil the U.S
how widespread is this so we've been
taking uh we've been taking steps over
the past couple of years diplomatically
wherever we've seen China trying to
create that kind of presence we've been
in there pushing back against it and
we've had some success in doing that
this is nothing new another area of CERN
China's role in fueling the production
of deadly fentanyl do you believe that
the Chinese State can really turn that
up and turn that down yes yes we we need
to see
much greater cooperation when it comes
to fentanyl I've had lawmakers in the
U.S say that this is done intentionally
by the Chinese state
do you believe that we've seen
cooperation from them in the past and
that's made a difference
that halted more or less over the last
few years he did Express optimism on
other issues
including the fate of three Americans
the U.S government says have been
wrongfully detained are we in a place
though as two governments where you're
negotiating or even talking about a
prisoner release or is this yes we are
you are we are
and there's progress uh again I don't
want to get into the the details but we
are very actively talking about that
critics of the Biden Administration
point to images like this propaganda
photo shown on Chinese TV to argue that
blinken looked too eager to follow
China's lead but blinken argues it would
be irresponsible not to negotiate what
made this trip worth it oh uh look I
think we were in a in a place where the
relationship was increasingly
unstable I think we've injected some
greater stability into it
Margaret on that point Before I Let You
Go did secretary blinken give you any
indication that President Biden might
actually meet with President XI in the
coming months
well Tony there's a very good chance
they meet this fall secretary blinken
told me that President XI may come to
the United States go to San Francisco in
November and may meet with President
Biden there at a summit of regional
leaders in the meantime you'll see more
cabinet officials come here the treasury
secretaries expected soon and since the
United States and China the world's two
largest economies and so intertwined
that's important uh I did ask secretary
blinken if President Biden would come to
Beijing he said Never Say Never but a
lot is riding on stabilizing this
tension Tony wow Margaret Brennan with a
big interview for us out of Beijing
today Margaret thank you very much